hola a todos en el último vídeo hablamos
de la divergencia y pusimos sobre la
mesa la intuición para entender la
verdad e imaginamos que nuestro campo
vectorial representa digamos alguna
forma de describir el fluido de no sé
digamos de agua o de ciertas partículas
que se mueven de acuerdo al vector al
cual están unidos verdad y ahí hay que
decir a cuál vector están unidos en cada
momento y en cada punto verdad porque
estos estas partículas al irse moviendo
pues tendrán un vector distinto asociado
y la pregunta clave que vamos a trabajar
es si tenemos digamos un punto dado
pensamos nos en algún punto dado por
aquí será que el fluido tiende a
acercarse hacia ese punto o tenderá más
bien a alejarse es decir sí tiende a
divergen o a converger verdad y lo que
quiero hacer es ir descubriendo una
fórmula para la divergencia y es que no
quiero solo dártela sino que sepas
realmente de dónde proviene así que
vayan
más abajo y consideremos una función
vectorial un campo vectorial verdad
pensemos en un campo vectorial que hemos
estado denotando con la letra de verdad
y digamos que este campo vectorial está
definido en el plano entonces tiene dos
variables de entrada y por supuesto la
salida será un vector con dos
componentes y típicamente a estas
componentes están descritas por dos
funciones que denotamos con p y q verdad
estas son funciones con valores
escalares y cada una representa una de
las componentes de nuestro campo
vectorial verdad entonces la la
divergencia digamos tendríamos que
comprenderla justamente como entendemos
a las derivadas tradicionales entonces
la divergencia por ejemplo si ésta es
ésta sería la anotación de lo que es la
divergencia ok y tendríamos que
pensarlas como como comprendemos a las
derivadas verdad la derivada de una
función
en realidad es como una como una especie
de operador verdad es decir nosotros le
damos una función y la derivada nos
devuelve otra función entonces la
divergencia verdad también tiene esa
propiedad nosotros le damos un campo
vectorial verdad y nos interesa por
supuesto en algún punto particular y lo
que nos devuelve es un valor escalar
verdad entonces la divergencia de un
campo vectorial será una función con
valores escalares pues sólo digamos nos
dará un número que nos diga si el fluido
tiende a divergen oa converger y no sólo
eso sino que además nos dice que tanto
divergió converge así que aquí
comenzaremos a pensar en casos digamos
donde la derivada es positiva donde es
negativa o donde es cero así que veamos
digamos un ejemplo rápido aquí pensemos
en la divergencia de nuestro campo
vectorial verdad en algún punto
particular del espacio x y pensemos que
es positiva entonces una imagen clásica
es la que vimos en el vídeo anterior en
donde tenemos un punto en donde no hay
nada de movimiento y todas las flechas
de alrededor apuntan digamos hacia
afuera de ese de ese punto entonces de
hecho hice una animación en el vídeo
anterior de esto verdad entonces aquí
tendríamos todos estos estos vectores
apuntando a fue hacia afuera del origen
y si nos fijamos en una región alrededor
todas las partículas se salen de la
región y esa es la idea central de la
divergencia positiva verdad y por
supuesto que no es la única posibilidad
para tener divergencia positiva por
ejemplo podríamos pensar algún punto por
aquí en donde digamos
un poco más abajo en donde tendremos
cierto flujo digamos y que en cierta
dirección hay una gran salida de este
fluido verdad mientras que en otra
dirección hay poca entrada entonces si
pensamos en una región alrededor digamos
de este punto podemos ver que la tasa a
la que salen las partículas es mucho más
grande que la tasa a la que entra en
verdad entonces de forma neta tendremos
una divergencia positiva verdad
estaríamos perdiendo densidad de nuestro
fluido otra forma
o más bien otra posibilidad es que la
divergencia de nuestro campo vectorial
de en un punto digamos
dado en el punto x coma ya sea negativo
verdad y en este caso el ejemplo o la
imagen típica es cuando todas las
flechas alrededor de nuestro punto
apuntan justamente hacia el verdad
entonces aquí tenemos un caso típico de
de cuando la divergencia es negativa y
el anime así en la animación del vídeo
anterior donde invertimos los vectores
verdad si dejamos correr el fluido la
densidad alrededor del origen aumenta
verdad justamente porque las partículas
convergen al origen pero otra vez no es
la única posibilidad verdad podríamos
pensar no sé en algún punto fijo del
espacio en donde salen las partículas a
una tasa muy pequeña pero entran muchas
o entran rápidamente verdad entonces si
pensamos en una región aquí verdad la
tasa a la que salen es mucho menor de la
que entran y por lo tanto tendremos que
la densidad aumenta verdad entonces la
divergencia en este caso también sería
negativa y finalmente pensemos un caso
en donde la divergencia es cero
pensemos un caso en donde la divergencia
de nuestro campo vectorial verdad en el
en algún punto particular
justamente vale cero y los ejemplos
típicos es como como los que también
vimos en el vídeo anterior en donde
realmente el campo vectorial pues no
tiene gran ciencia verdad sigue una
trayectoria muy muy simple pero también
podríamos pensar en un punto en donde
todo lo que entra verdad ya de alguna
forma se balancea con lo que sale verdad
más o menos esta sería la idea de un
caso en donde la divergencia es cero así
que estas son las ideas que me gustaría
que tuvieras en mente antes de buscar la
fórmula de lo que es la divergencia en
sí misma verdad y lo que haré en el
próximo vídeo 2 es fijarnos en nuestras
funciones p y q aquí tenemos nuestra
función p nuestra función q y vamos a
retomar sus derivadas derivadas
parciales y vamos a pensar cómo se
relacionan con estas ideas que hemos
estado creando
alrededor de la divergencia nos vemos